flag day in russia a nation at war even
if war is not the word being used by
moscow
flags in kiev too along with a lineup of
captured russian tanks independence day
marking the end of soviet rule is
wednesday which happens to be exactly
six months since russia's invasion began
on the weekend president vladimir
zelinsky said russia might be planning
particularly ugly attacks to coincide
with the date so mass gatherings will be
banned in kiev
moscow is likely smarting from recent
attacks deep inside crimea the ukrainian
region annexed by russia eight years ago
and now there's the fallout from
saturday's killing of daria dugina the
daughter of far-right russian ideologue
alexander dugan russia's secret service
claims it has cracked the case already
accusing a ukrainian traveling with her
twelve-year-old daughter of planting the
bomb and fleeing to estonia an adviser
to zielinski calls it russian propaganda
as ever speculation is rife as to what
is really going on so this could be one
of these psychological operations
of here
this happened and now uh ukraine is
guilty and now we have to also discuss
this at the negotiation team ukrainian
canadian defense consultant lada
rozlicki says dark humor is the weapon
of choice many ukrainians will be using
to get through this week we will
celebrate and we will use that humor but
we're all afraid some revenge from the
kremlin may be exacted here in the
russian-controlled city of mariupol
ukraine says russia is setting up a show
trial for captured ukrainians from the
azov battalion planned it says
for wednesday redmond shannon global
news london